here with some perspective senior
political analyst Brit Hume good evening
Brett your thoughts on all this today
well it was pretty striking and sudden
it was true of course that he was
expected to retire within a matter of
months but no not necessarily today and
of course the sequence of events raises
questions here you have this you know
this the staff memo compendium that the
house that the Republican staff on the
House Intelligence Committee put
together and room
McCabe's boss mr. ray goes up to Capitol
Hill to look at it and the next day
McCabe is forced out now you know that
may just be a coincidence but but I
think you know we all be justified in
suspecting that something in that
document alarmed ray longer alarm
Kristopher ray and he gave the word to
McKay but buddy you better get out of
here before this hits so we'll see and
of course we wait as Katherine Harris is
reporting the decision on whether the
public release it publicly release that
document immediately or after the after
the White House weighs in on it alrighty
the president obviously has been
favorably disposed toward it here's what
Democrats say pretty much in unison and
that is all of this is designed as a
distraction away from the Muller
investigation into Russian collusion and
wherever Muller goes and to that they
say it's striking that an administration
is taking such strikes and swipes at the
FBI that had been largely respected for
decades that's what Democrats say up on
Capitol Hill they certainly do Bret and
if it turns out that there's nothing
whatever to these suggestions that
there's been improper conduct by the FBI
and perhaps officials that main justice
during the course of these
investigations that went into Hillary
Clinton's campaign and the one into
Donald Trump in his campaign then we'll
all say well that was an unfair hit the
FBI took but we don't know that yet
and there certainly has been enough
smoke in the in the form of these highly
partisan antitrump text messages that
we've seen from
atop justice and FBI investigators to
make us wonder about it
what's more you know there's no reason
that two investigations can't go forward
simultaneously there's no reason to
think that any of this is gonna is gonna
derail the Muller investigation so my
feeling about that is to for people to
say it's a distraction and there's
damaging suggests that you know the
American people cannot contemplate two
investigations at once I think that's
nonsense right and for someone like a
former federal prosecutor electric Audi
to say that he's very concerned about
what he's seen obviously raises a lot of
eyebrows up there it does and Trey
Gowdy's a guy that's been pretty
responsible on this obviously either
he's a Republican no doubt about that
and he has partisan objectives perhaps
but look it was trey Gowdy that de
parently talked Devon Nunez into having
the FBI director come up to examine that
memo ahead of time and and and new news
and his team there are being pretty
careful about this I mean he didn't just
they didn't just do what we might have
expected to happen which is for the
document to be leaked they're going
through the houses formal process for
declassification of material which I
think is is responsible so there's some
reason to take what's what's in that
document seriously I would think we will
see what happens tonight Brit as always
thank you thank you Brett